البدايه من السودان حيث اعلنت الخارجيه
السعوديه عن اتفاق بين الجيش ودعم السريع
لوقف النار لمده 24 ساعه يبدا صباح السبت
اكدت السعوديه وامريكا في بيان مشترك انه
في حال عدم التزام الطرفي الصراع فسيكونان
مضطرين بصفتهما ميسرين لحوار بتاجيل
المحادثات في جده كذا انهما يشاركان الشعب
السوداني حاله الاحباط جراء عدم التزامي
بالهدى السابقه
نذهب الى جده الان لمعرفه المزيد من
التفاصيل ومعنى من هناك موفده العربيه
لينا يعقوب لينا مرحبا بك معنا في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه على العربيه ما الذي
استجد ليعود الحديث عن هدنه وهدنه معلنه
الان
مرحبا بك يا نادين بعد تعليق المحادثات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع هي محادثات كانت
غير مباشره
انخرطت الوفود مره اخرى في اجتماعات
للوصول الى هذه الهدنه وهي تشمل تسهيل
الحركه للمساعدات الانسانيه وبان تصل الى
جميع انحاء البلاد باعتبار ان الهدن
السابقه فشلت بصوره كبيره في ان تجعل
المساعدات تصل الى مستحقيها والى المناطق
المتضرره هذا الاتفاق ايضا بموجبه الذي
سيكون من اوسع يبدا من غدا الساعه السادسه
صباحا حتى السادسه من صباح الاحد
بوقف الهجمات والقصف المدفعي وعدم استخدام
الطائرات المسيره
وكافه انواع الاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله بين
الجيش والدعم السريع وهي تفتح فرصه جديده
لاعاده بناء الثقه بين الوفدين على امل ان
تكون هناك مفاوضات تسهم بصوره كبيره لوقف
اطلاق النار وابعاد قوات الدعم السريع عن
العاصمه الخرطوم وهو مطلب كان معروف في
السابق بحيث ان هذه الاقتتال يدور في
مناطق مدنيه سكنيه وهو ما اشار اليه بيان
مسهل الحوار طيب امام هذه المطالب لينا هل
قدم اي من الطرفين بعضا من الشروط ربما
القبول بهذه الهدنه
لا شروط نادين تم القبول بهذه الاسره
الهدنه والاتفاق على الالتزام بما ورد
فيها من نقاط نحن نعلم ان هناك محورين
الاول يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار والثاني
يتعلق بالترتيبات الانسانيه والترتيبات
الانسانيه تعني بصوره مباشره تسهيل حركه
الاغاثه عدم اعتراضها عدم اعتراض التفتيش
عدم اطلاق نار بقرب المناطق المراد توزيع
المواد فيها سواء كان مواد اغاثيه او
ادويه تصل الى المستشفيات ووقف ايضا
لاطلاق النار لتسهيل حركه المواطنين بصوره
كبيره في الاوقات السابقه كانت هناك
اشتباكات اما باسلحه خفيفه او اسلحه ثقيله
لذلك هذه الهدنه مدتها قصيره
الكثيرين يتفاءلون بامكانيه تنفيذها لان
مدتها 24 ساعه فقط ليست لمده اسبوع او
عشره ايام
كما كانت في السابق لذلك الشعور بان هذه
الهدنه يلتزم بها الطرفين هو اكبر من قبل
والاغراض تبدو واضحه وبعد ذلك قد تكون
هناك اعاده ثقه لبدء محادثات جديده كما
يقول مسهل عمليه الحوار يعني لنا نفهم بان
هناك مؤشرات لان يتم تمديد الهدنه لاكثر
من 24 ساعه في حال كانت الامور سليمه بين
الطرفين
ربما ان التزم الطرفين بهذه الهدنه قد
يكون هناك نقاش جديد ليس الغرض فقط تمديد
الهدنه الى مده اطول ولكن الغرض ايضا حل
المشكله بصوره جذريه واضافه بعض البنود
التي كان يطالب بها مثلا الجيش او حتى
يطلب يطلبها الدعم السريع الجيش كان من
المعروف انه يطالب بضروره الالتزام بنقاط
معينه ومحدده وارده في الاتفاق تتمثل
باخلاء المستشفيات وعدم احتلال مساكن
المواطنين والخروج من هذه البيوت السكنيه
والدعم السريع ايضا كان يضع بعض
الاشتراكات منها ان الجيش يقوم بقصف
مواقعه وقواته في اماكن معينه وهو الامر
الذي ادى الى فشل الهدنه الاولى والثانيه
لذلك قد تكون هناك نقاشات بصوره جديده وقد
ذكر وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان في مؤتمره الصحفي مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكل على ان هناك قد
تكون هناك اليه رقابه اكثر تشددا منذ قبل
توضح مواطن الخلل في هذا الاتفاق شكرا
جزيلا لك من جد موفضه العربيه لهناك لنا
يعقوب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات